when you go back home and your dad says
you know Alexander always has been
pretty loose with the alcohol and he
says this to somebody else in the family
when you're at dinner I am super
aggressive about this I'm like what the
do you want me to be worse do you
want me to be loose with alcohol what do
you want because by you saying that it
encourages it it reinforces that
behavior so don't speak that over me now
me saying it like this is how I talk to
people that will probably make you
uncomfortable it will certainly make
them uncomfortable but the thing is is
that when you go back home if you have
to go back home you have to draw
lines in the sand and say like you will
not treat me this way let me teach you
how to treat me